New enemies, old allies, and a deadly family
feud… the challenges don't look to be any
easier for John Wick in the fourth chapter
of his revenge story.
A little over halfway through the first full
trailer for "John Wick: Chapter 4," John Wick
approaches an outdoor table in Paris behind
which the Eiffel Tower looms large.
There, he sits across from the Marquis de
Gramont in order to discuss the terms of an
agreement that appears will grant Wick his
freedom from the High Table's pursuit.
There's only one condition – he has to defeat
the Marquis in single combat.
Briefly visible during this short sequence
are the presences of Winston behind Wick and
Donnie Yen's Caine on the Marquis' side of
the table.
This configuration offers a look at what seems
to be the two principal factions in "John
Wick: Chapter 4," with Winston notably backing
Wick despite what appeared to be an outright
betrayal of his old friend at the end of "Chapter
3 – Parabellum."
John Wick is also seen battling Caine at the
trailer's conclusion, suggesting their fight
might come near the film's climax.
Given Caine's presence at the Marquis' side
earlier on in the trailer, it's likely this
battle against Caine is directly relevant
to the overarching conflict with the Marquis
with Wick's freedom on the line.
The final scenes of "John Wick: Chapter 3
– Parabellum" saw the protagonist's long-term
ally, Winston, shoot him over a balcony.
The Continental owner wanted to keep his power,
and he couldn't side with a rogue assassin
who was being hunted down by all of the High
Table's minions.
So, he struck a deal with The Adjudicator
that unfortunately led to John having to take a tumble.
The trailer for "John Wick: Chapter 4" seems
to show John and Winston having a civilized
conversation, suggesting that the former has
forgiven his old ally's transgressions.
At the same time, it's possible that Winston
never intended to kill everyone's favorite
dog-loving assassin in the first place.
After all, Winston was hardly surprised when
The Adjudicator informed him that John had
survived the aforementioned attack.
Was it part of a plan that only he and John
were in on?
One particularly interesting aspect of the
"John Wick: Chapter 4" trailer comes at the
1-minute and 3-second mark when the ever-suave
Winston and the ever-smug Bowery King appear
to be exiting a subway train.
The two characters have both offered assistance
to John, but they're not exactly known to
hang out together.
The implication seems to be that they're together
and that there might even be some sort of
alliance between the two.
However, the short glimpse only shows the
Bowery King exiting, leaving the actual nature
of the situation deliciously unclear.
Are the two on their way to have a stealthy
meeting, perhaps summoned by John?
Could Winston be tailing the Bowery King for
some reason?
Are both characters secretly super into crotcheting,
and this sort of stealthy transportation is
the only way they can meet and make colorful
hacky sacks without losing face in the hardcore
world they live in?
It's probably not that last one, but until
further trailers or the movie sheds light
on their travels' purpose, there's always
hope.
The High Table in the "John Wick" franchise
is the mysterious organization that essentially
runs the secretive world of assassins and
organized crime.
Although each movie reveals another aspect
of this hidden world, the High Table is an
incredibly powerful organization, and their
word is essentially law.
"John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum" features
Wick attempting to clear his name after executing
a member of the High Table on neutral ground,
which is a grievous mistake in the eyes of
this organization.
For his actions, Wick is considered incommunicado,
and a large bounty is placed on his head.
After a bombastic finale in "Parabellum,"
Wick escapes from the clutches of the High
Table, and it seems as if he will still have
to deal with them in "John Wick: Chapter 4."
However, the trailer reveals that his family
sits at the High Table.
"I don't sit at the table."
"Your family does."
This could mean that he has a sibling or parent
that wields this powerful authority, or it
could be a reference to the Belarusians from
"Parabellum."
This may be the reason why John has been able
to survive against such insurmountable odds
time and time again.
Either way, it seems like yet another dynamic
has been interjected into the "John Wick"
mythos, and it will be interesting to see
if this new Wick family individual or group
on the High Table is a friend or foe.
While the "John Wick: Chapter 4" trailer is
filled with moments of chaos, intrigue, and
nail-biting thrills, it does feature a cute
nod to one of Keanu Reeves's most iconic performances
to break the tension.
A minute into the trailer, a freshly suited-up
Wick says,
"I'm going to need a gun."
Reeves and Fishburne were first seen together
in 1999's "The Matrix."
In the film, Reeves' character asks for:
"Guns.
Lots of guns."
The quick line of dialogue from Reeves' Neo
has gone on to become synonymous with "The
Matrix," a film that, in part, is responsible
for the "John Wick" franchise.
The late '90s sci-fi flick saw Chad Stahelski
taking on the role of Reeves' stunt double.
Stahelski would later go on to become the
martial arts stunt coordinator for the two
back-to-back "Matrix" sequels.
After a decade-plus of stunt work, Stahelski
decided his next challenge would be directing,
roping in Reeves to headline the titular role
in 2014's "John Wick."
The second flick in the franchise saw Morpheus
actor Fishburne join the nefarious world of
contract killings.
Now all audiences need is an appearance from
Carrie-Anne Moss to complete the "Matrix" trinity.
The line from "The Matrix" was previously
referenced verbatim in "John Wick: Chapter
3 – Parabellum."
"Guns.
Lots of guns."
Only time will tell just how many times Wick's
fourth outing will reference the Wachowski
sisters' game-changing sci-fi franchise.